welcome to this webinar
where we will speak about our new
product
that we have been working on the omics
logic code playground
code playground is the place to learn
and practice bioinformatics coding by
following interactive tutorials and
completing challenges
in r and python these courses
and exercises will help you understand
how to
analyze and visualize omics data
to extract meaningful insights from
large
biological datasets we hope that you too
will use this resource to learn
practice and achieve bioinformatics
greatness
with concise exercises and interesting
challenges
right in the comfort of your browser
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omix logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of our growing community
before we begin
let me introduce what omits logic is and
how the training resources we will
discuss
today have been developed and are used
in the omics logic training programs and
for research support
in academic institutions around the
world
i'm honored to have been working with a
team that collectively
have amazing experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background
with expertise in oncology immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation has a
long-standing recognition for his
generous support
of many international projects and
research activities
one of these projects is the
establishment of the
tubber bioinformatics research center
which has been
at the core of what we do dr leonard
brotsky is the director of the turbo
bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career
has developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research
in biotechnology pharmaceutical research
and development
agriculture and basic research what we
will discuss today
is a result of hard work by some of the
people
mentioned here julia pinoff is an
expert bioinformatician and helped
prepare many of the materials we will
use
avi titivski is a computer scientist and
leads the development of the tbi info
platform
that we use in our omics logic programs
dr mohit mazumdar is in charge of
business development
and a project mentor joshua
maintains the educational portal
and of course there are many more that i
simply do not have the
time to mention today
omics logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between pine biotech
and innovative big data analytics
company
based in the us and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic programs have
been thoroughly tested
around the world and are known to lead
to excellent outcomes for students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors as well as
faculty interested in
data science and biomedical research
now i would want to invite elia brodsky
the ceo
and co-founder of pine biotic to talk
more about this platform with you
over to you elia
thank you very much and i'm happy to see
many of you that we've gotten to know in
the past programs and
in different types of situations so
what i'll do today is briefly introduce
you
to this new and exciting project for us
which was the development of the code
omixlogic playground
so as beeps mentioned my name is elia
brodsky for those of you that are
joining for the first time i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pi biotech
and i want to tell you a little bit
about what pine biotech is seeking to
achieve
our vision is to enhance human health
and well-being
by enabling biological discovery with
relevant
data solutions and expert support
and so we've been working for the past
couple of years
on developing a number of resources that
will allow biologists to easily manage
process analyze and visualize their data
so as a result as you know we have
developed
a number of educational resources that
include our
t-biome for platform that was designed
and developed at the tower
bioinformatics research center
and our team has been working on
applying some of the methods
in that platform to allow a seamless
transition
from learning about bioinformatics to
specializing
in different bioinformatics domains and
applications
to then translating that knowledge and
those skills to independent projects
that could be supported by our team
and so as we looked at the field that
we're in
we realized that we discovered
that these tools are basically
creating a solution for the gap
in research and discovery and an
important part of that solution
is coding so we realize that as students
become proficient in the logic of
bioinformatics and are able to apply
different methods for processing big
data they need to
be more empowered with downstream
analysis tools that include a typical
collection of
different libraries and code blocks in r
and python
and so then we started working on
expanding that
idea into a product into a solution that
i think
fits in very nicely with the rest of the
tools that we have
so as a result working with our team
we've designed and developed this
omix logic code playground the
playground
allows a user to learn
about different types of challenges
understand the code approach and then
actually practice that code
within the browser and so the way that
we
kind of thought about this is that we
want to allow people to understand what
are some of the challenges
learn the different pieces of code and
the syntax
to be able to start off with a template
that they can modify including the
different
outputs and the settings and then learn
to apply that
to a data set of their own and by
incorporating this into the other
solutions that we already have
into the tbi info platform and into the
educational portal
we are able to really fill in that gap
that allows
biologists and people with a minimal
technical background to really develop
coding skills
as they work on projects of their own
and so
as we have done with the t-biome from
platform
our objective over the course of the
next several months
is to really supplement the areas of
analysis for genomic
transcriptomic epigenomic metagenomic
and proteomic data
with these tools and methods that we
will provide tutorials on
in different languages like r and python
so today i wanted to start off with a
brief demonstration of how it actually
works
so for all of those that are new to the
omixlogic
playground i want to ask you to go to
codeomicslogic.com and vip say if you
could please
paste that in the chat
so if you could go to this website
the registration is free so if you have
not registered
already you can just go ahead and
register for free
and you will see that in each category
of courses we have some
free resources that you can leverage
right away
so please let me know once you've been
able to reach this page
and i'll continue from there
once you create your account and you log
in you will have access
to different courses and so we wanted to
start with this set of courses
that allows anyone to get started with
code being in
r python an introduction to data science
and then several examples applied to
genomic data
metagenomic data and transcriptomic data
our goal is to add new lessons and
courses
every week to this platform so we hope
that this is just a resource
that we are getting started with and
today i will also
show you how easy it is to add new
lessons and tutorials
so for those of you that are interested
in working with us
on expanding this resource we are happy
to
connect with you and discuss what are
the opportunities to actually
expand this resource and utilize in
different domains
so right now we are applying this to the
domain that we're in and the onyx logic
training and i'll talk a little bit more
about how we do this in the onyx logic
programs
and if you have an idea for a tutorial
in r or python
i will show you how easy it is to add a
new resource
onto this platform and make it available
online
so as you join i want to demonstrate one
of the examples it's not going to take a
very long time
but we can actually try to do this
together so that you really get a sense
of
what can be done in a very short period
of time
and how the courses expand your
understanding of bioinformatics
in application to different types of
data sets and
an in-depth look at the different types
of
challenges that are solved with these
analyses
so let's go to introduction to data
science in r
you can see here a description of the
overall course
this introduction to data science in r
is a part of our data science omixlogic
training program
but it can also be standalone
should we use this to create an account
for code playground
yes again for those of you that
already have a an account
on the educational portal you can
actually use the same
email address and i will show you how
the two are connected
so they are interconnected as you know
we use this point
system to track activity and all of
those are integrated
and you will notice that within each
course
there are going to be several lessons
that are free
and several lessons that are called
premium now this premium option
comes at a minimal price the
subscription
is 10 a month and as i mentioned
these types of tutorials will expand as
we move forward
every week our plan is to add new
material to this site
so once you're in this course let's open
up
dimensionality reduction principle
component analysis and visualization
just so that i have a sense of how many
of you are with me
and adapt my pace accordingly could you
let me know
if you've reached this course so i know
how many of you are following along
all right excellent thank you very much
okay so principal component analysis
allows us to study
continuous data for example gene
expression data
to understand how the gene expression
characterizes samples placing them
into a single multi-dimensional space
and reducing the dimensionality so that
we can understand
differences between samples or groups of
samples
in a scatter plot in a visual output
so here we describe the input data you
can see the input data is a set of
samples characterized by 15 genes
with their gene expression values listed
right here in the cells
a little bit about this data set this
data set comes from a cancer study
that is focused on identifying different
subtypes
of cancer so let's take a look at how we
can apply
principal component analysis in r so
that we understand the
syntax the analysis approach and what
are some of the different options that
you can modify
and use to improve the basic
visualization
so as you can read right here the first
thing that we have to do
is load some libraries as anyone who's
used r
before you know that one of the major
challenges
is setting up your environment and so
that's the first thing that we want to
eliminate
by offering this platform instead of
dealing with everyone installing the
different packages
and resolving dependencies and maybe not
having the right
version to be able to run something we
want to just jump into the code
and understand what it does so as you
read through this
we will refer to the specific libraries
and then we will explain how the data is
loaded in
and transformed so that it is ready
for the analysis now what's amazing
about
our and many of the packages in python
is that
the actual analysis could be done in a
couple of lines of code
so it's really easy to learn and get
started without being overwhelmed
with how to actually structure your
analysis
so what we do here is use a basic
analysis with principal component which
is achieved by
doing pr comp to the transpose data
table
that we loaded in and a very simple
output is just creating a scatter plot
of principal components that looks
already somewhat informative now as we
go through the rest of the code you will
see how we can
improve the output adding colors
adding the loadings for the different
genes that we have or the features
and eventually plotting this in 3d
so let's take a look at how to do this
importantly we don't want to just
provide you with an opportunity to
rewrite the code copy and paste and then
see the result we also want to
understand
what this analysis does along the way
so let's take a look here you have an
editable piece of code
that you can try running right away so
if you click on run
the code will run in the cloud and
produce
an output
okay so you can see that the output is
being produced those images are going to
load
and let's just take a look at what we
did here so we have
a file this file is stored on github
and then we can read the table convert
it to
a matrix transpose the matrix
and then run our principal component
after we run the principal component you
see that we can plot it
or we can even print out what is inside
of this result because r is an
object-oriented language
we can actually print it so we can add
here print
pca so let's run it again
and we see what is in the object so in
the object we have
all of our genes and we have some
principal
component analysis results so you can
see here
pc one two three etc so
what we do is we actually take this
analysis and we can
visualize it using the standard scatter
plot option
which is shown right here plot pca
at x and y or we can use
the gg fortify
package which allows us to create a gt
plot
object that is easy to work with to
improve the visualization
and add all kinds of additional
information onto this single plot
so what's important here is that we've
explained the code
and explained the problem and then we
also demonstrate how you actually
run it right within the browser being
able to modify
different aspects of this code to be
able to improve the visualization
or even change the file that you're
working with so change the data set very
easily
so here we explain some additional
information
about this code including an insight
into how to add some more information
for example to output a textual
result which will be a file
so if you look at this new area you can
try writing this code
and adding this part of the script right
here
if i run this as it is so if a student
wants to just
run whatever and complete all of the
steps without
thinking about the problem they won't be
able to so you can see that i'm
getting an error and i can see what the
air is and the air
as obviously seen as seen right here
is that the code is incomplete and i
even have
the red parentheses here that show me
that it's incomplete
so what do i have to do now the student
or the participant who's trying to learn
r
really needs to go back and see what am
i trying to do and how can i do it on my
own
so actually this part is very new so
this is going to be very simple to solve
let's solve it together
so here we see what the code does we
load the library
we have the input file already we define
the data
we even have the sample names already
and pca is also already
mentioned here but what we have here is
printing the length of pca result
object so how do we print the length of
this object
we simply take this and place it inside
the parentheses
so if i want to print the full object
i just do pca result if i want to know
the length of this object i have to put
it within the parentheses
and here it says add here the script to
print the results table
now here i have how this table would be
printed so i can for now
just copy and paste it right here
let's clear the console
and run it again
okay and here we discovered uh there's
another
problem so let's see what the issue is
okay right here so make the plot from
the previous step
so we also need to make the plot so how
did we make the plot previously
we did auto plot that for
the pca right so we can just copy that
right here
let's place it here again let's clear
the console
excellent so our code is successful and
the answer is correct
so for each time that we run this code
you're actually rewarded with points
encouraging you to complete and build up
your profile
as you master these basic skills now we
learned
how to load data how to transform data
how to
analyze data and also how to explore
different types of outputs including
visual
and textual so if we look at this text
we can now see
this is a table that shows us the
position of the samples
in the principal component space
but it's not so easy to understand what
does that actually mean so here we have
the example of that
output what are these principal
components
why are we getting a 2d scatter plot
instead of a
3d scatter plot so how do we actually
understand
what this information can provide us
with if you plot the pca
object with a bar plot you will also get
an
understanding of how this pca
result characterizes the full data set
and we can see here that the principal
component one
is the most informative component so it
captures the most variability between
different samples but as those pcs
continue to add on and all together form
a hundred percent we can kind of see the
threshold
after pc5 they're non-informative
of course to get a scatter plot we
cannot visualize
all of the data in all of the components
the maximum we can do is three
so if we visualize that in 3d
we will actually see the relationship
between the components
and what they mean and how twisting and
combining different principal components
together
can help us visualize the differences
between the samples
so let's learn about how to do this in
the next step
by going beyond the basics
so if you open the next step you will
see that we will start
improving on this basic visualization
and try to apply clustering
in this multi-dimensional space to
understand
what new information we can get out of
this analysis
so here you can see that we have a basic
way to perform pcea which is
pr comp and create an object
we can change the way that we analyze
instead of pierre comp
using k means and for k means we all
know that we need the number for the k
so the number of expected class classes
or the clusters that we expect here
now if we print this we will see that an
additional level of
information is added to our
output however the output
looks like com the cluster
cluster number one combines normal-like
and bazel samples so these are
two different subtypes of cancer but
they are combined into a single cluster
and for example here we have an overlap
between luminal
and basal and normal-like and here we
also have
two different clusters for the luminal
so
something doesn't seem right
if we use a different method so instead
of
k means there's an additional message
there are additional methods called
clara feni or pam which stands for
clustering large applications clustering
or for pam it's partitioning around
midioids
and we can try how these different
additional types of clustering
can help us understand what is in our
data
so if we change from that function
to other methods of clustering we will
get a different result so let's
try to evaluate what we are getting in
this output it looks like
with this output normal-like and basal
are almost perfectly separated except
for a small
overlap right here with basal being in
the normal like
but basil from luminal and from cloud
and low
are actually separated quite well
we can also see that principal component
has the percentage
and pc one indeed explains 55 percent of
the variance
as opposed to pc2 only 18.34
so let's see if we understood how to
write this code
first of all we have the library already
loaded can i just run this
unfortunately there is no input file
either so now i have to add
more of the code so in this
ability to learn about the code go
through the problem statement
and start developing coding skills what
we do
is we go through these simple
explanations
show how easy it is to modify the
settings and then put a challenge in
front of you
using this challenge students are going
to be motivated because they understand
how easy it is
but at the same time they really have to
understand that they're able to do this
independently each time that a student
completes a code block they're rewarded
with points
and those points are being reported
under their profile
anyone that wants to then take this code
over to them so let's say you wrote an
elaborate code
and you made this code look exactly like
you want
this and you want to save it for future
reference how do you actually get the
code
well it's very easy at the bottom of
each one of your code blocks you have
this copy button
and it copies to the clipboard and now
you can just
open this in your rstudio and run it
from there
so what this does is it allows
anyone to try to work through the
problem in the browser
helping understand what is the correct
answer
what are the mistakes and running it
right within the browser to not have to
deal with any installation
or any kind of technical
setting that they have on their computer
after they complete this and you can see
that this is the challenge so after they
complete the challenge
they get an additional number of points
for completing the whole lesson
the progress is being tracked so if i go
back to my courses you can see that
for those courses that i have started uh
this is being tracked and importantly
this is going to be in the achievements
right here so maybe some of you
are recognizing some of your names
because
you are at you are completing some of
the code blocks
and you're trying to do some of this
analysis together with me
so all of this is being tracked and what
we hope to do
by offering you a short survey
at the end of each course is to
understand
how the participants learn
and are able to apply different methods
to different types of
data sets and eventually start offering
a recommendation so really to make it
personalized
and uh offer the suggestion for what you
should do next
based on your objective now importantly
all of this information is linked in
with your account
that account is linked also to our main
educational portal so if i go here to
the educational portal
for those of you that already have an
account
i can also see that you're completing
those steps
and i know what we are working on so all
of these people are working on
principal component analysis all of this
information is stored under your profile
combined with the theoretical courses
that you take
on the educational portal as well as the
pipelines that you run
on the server that t bio info platform
not only that the t bioinfo platform is
also connected
by offering short scripts for different
types of methods
that you can directly put into the code
onyx logic playground
to try and rewrite the scripts that the
platform use
uses as you do different types of
analyses
for example if i go to my pipelines
i know that recently i ran a pca on the
platform
inside the outputs there is a result
file
but i can also get an r script if i was
using not the regular pca
but the pcar library so from a
perspective
of an educator i can build the
experience
to go from very simple and theoretical
to practical in the sense of a user of
bioinformatics
to a person who's familiar with what
stands behind each button
and how they can develop independent
skills to continue and develop
their bioinformatics capacity
i hope that this was an informative
demonstration
again we have options for both r and
python
and if you have any questions please put
them in the chat
so i'll be happy to respond to them
right now before i move on
to how this looks from someone who wants
to contribute
to this platform and develop tutorials
in python and
r using the code omixlogic
playground
okay so not everyone at once i hope and
keep your
questions uh if you have any other
questions you're welcome to email us
to marketing at pine.bio we'll be happy
to continue to speak with you about it
so the courses that we've developed so
far cover
a basic introduction to bioinformatics
developing a sense of data science
and some basic courses in genomics
metagenomics and transcriptomics
okay so there's a question if i want to
load an existing file on my desktop to
the platform how am i going to do that
so i'm actually going to show you in a
second what the back end looks like
and explain how you can create your own
tutorial
right here on the platform storing your
data and images
within the course so here i have
um and by the way for
if you mean as a user as a student how
do you load an existing file
on your desktop to the platform i can
show you that in python
in just a second so the objective of the
courses that we have
is to go from the very beginning by
loading files
to then knowing how to visualize
the data and doing summary statistics
analyzing the data for
variants and other types of statistical
characterization doing exploratory
analysis
and eventually being familiar with the
different types of challenges
addressed in genomics metagenomics
transcriptomics
and other type of data as you know these
courses
are project driven so we made it so that
people can
try to apply the same methods to their
own data
without having to rework everything but
really
understanding the logic and being able
to simply
replace the files with whatever they um
are interested to use uh now
i showed you today how it looks in uh
python r
and i want to show you in a couple of
minutes of what it looks like in python
as well
so let's go back and load
a different course so i'm just going to
go back to the courses page
and we'll go to getting started with
bioinformatics in python
and i'm going to load this course called
reading dna using python
so this is a part of their introduction
to bioinformatics course and it's fairly
simple
and it's going to be quick i think for
you to understand of what
it does at the basic level and then i'll
show you a little bit more advanced
course that you can load files from your
computer as well
okay so once i'm here you can see that
the explanation
goes into the actual code of dna so we
have to deal here with sequences so this
is
uh you know the type of analysis that
you would want to do
and you would want to maybe align
sequences and compare their length
and what you read here in the beginning
is how
the code actually works what it does
and at the end you've learned the code
that will create a program to analyze
dna so then you can see
how here we have a simple uh
a simple uh code to analyze
a certain sequence so for example try to
print the length of a dna sequence 10
bases in length
to complete this task so following the
instructions
right here if i have a sequence
i can measure how long is that sequence
right so here
if i have my first piece of code
i can paste it right here and let's try
to run it and i have success running
code and the answer is
correct now you can also see that i can
drop a file right here so i can
literally take
any file from my computer and just drop
it right here
for the for this browser-based analysis
to recognize that i have
a file stored in the browser in the
browser cache
and i recommend that you go through some
of the
other tutorials that we have to see how
you can use that option to try to
analyze
different types of data producing
visualization
statistical analysis and even training
and evaluating machine learning models
for those that want to use this in r
it's not exactly as simple by just
dragging and dropping the file here
you do have to upload your excel file to
some kind of a cloud system and so
for those of you that are just users
it's easy to leverage
github or maybe google drive to try and
do that
but if you are a developer and maybe
a faculty member and you would like to
develop additional resources for your
students
to learn coding in python and art i want
to show you
how easy it is to create such tutorials
that you can
publish on the platform
and by the way if you are interested uh
go ahead and reach out to us
and we'll be happy to set you up with an
account so you can try this on your own
so you can see here the back end of this
platform
it looks exactly the same i see all of
the courses that i created
or the courses that other people have
created so these are my courses
and i can add a course so
when i add the course i need to add
description maybe
an image something like that and i
already have it set it up
i have it set up right here for this
test course
it's not published and not released so
no one can really see what i'm doing
let's go in this course here i added a
couple of lessons
and a test lesson that we can try to
modify
just so that you can see how easy it is
to do this
so in the back end i have a few options
i can
make this into an r code or a python
code
so you can determine what it's going to
be
here i can choose a file if i need to a
description
and save and i can make this a free or
a paid course and here i can add steps
so if i have multiple steps for example
in the beginning
i would like to maybe just explain
what this is going to be about once the
people
understand what this is about i want to
reward them so i
want to give them some achievement
points right here
and then i can add either a text block
for example
this is a test course so i can actually
write this here and i can
modify the way it looks or i can even
add here just directly by copying and
pasting
from a course that i already have for
example if i have a course here
on phylogenetic analysis i can just
take all of this text including the
images just
copy it and paste it over to see it
pop up exactly the way it was so it's
really simple
to go from existing drafts that you
might have
to a course that is going to become
interactive
how do i actually add that interactive
portion
here i can add videos
videos images code so if i want to write
some syntax so library ape
for example right and i can also
add different types of
um code blocks so for example if i
created the second step uh try
this out and i'll say code
tried and then here i'll give it
200 points for example and i want to add
a code block so here in this code block
i can just take this
code that i already have written out
right here
write it in here
and test it on my computer to know what
is the expected answer
so i just place the answer that i expect
to get from
this analysis and give it a number of
completion points
to know how to evaluate
the result so as i go through this
process
i can create a step-by-step tutorial
that introduces the code block or maybe
even the specific data set that i want
to explain the challenge of that data
set then help
by understanding the syntax and trying
to run that syntax on your own
and maybe creating a challenge with a
specific
outcome that could be the exact same
output that i'm getting
in my rstudio or python developer
environment on my
computer so it's really simple to add
this
to the repository to the library of
different resources
for those of you that are faculty and
are interested in contributing
please do reach out to us so we can show
you how to create an account
as a faculty or as a student
the courses that we mentioned again if
we
go through some of the courses that we
have right here
are going to be expanding every week we
hope to add some new resources and in
fact
the course that i was just showing you
right now
uh is uh added right here to compare
dna sequences using phylogenetic
analysis so we have
a full description of the ape library
where you can build phylogenetic trees
and analyze similarities between
sequences
and we will continue to expand this to
other
areas as well now before
we uh complete the session i also
understand that there is a big demand
for those of you that might be
interested in something like this
but don't know how to get started so let
me briefly introduce
how we provide hands-on training
for this kind of coding bioinformatics
linking together the different elements
the theoretical
the practical and the skill based like
coding
into different types of programs
for those participants that are
interested in learning
and developing a project of their own
we have a program for advanced users
and for those that are just getting
started we have very introductory
programs
that require minimal technical
background and we'll introduce them to
the
different ranges of applications of
bioinformatics so
a number of different bioinformatics
projects
for example right now we are running a
program called
introduction to bioinformatics this
program is designed
to provide the very basics without
any technical capability illustrating
how the different processing
analysis visualization and
interpretation methods
can help you understand the application
of bioinformatics to cancer biology
agriculture
neurodegenerative diseases and
infectious diseases
so in this program we have
six different sessions that are
interactive
so we meet twice a week we discuss
different theoretical aspects that are
supplemented by
independent activities that they can
complete on the educational portal
on the server big data analysis platform
and on the code playground now the code
playground is optional for the
introduction
introductory course but it is something
that we go in much deeper as we continue
with the data science program so the
data science program is actually
designed
with a much greater focus on the
application of different types of
analysis methods to understand different
types of omics data
understand what happens behind the
scenes of each one of the buttons
and also is an excellent introduction
into the domain
of machine learning for data mining
and for predictive analysis so we put an
emphasis
on such things as different methods of
clustering
application to different types of data
sets and
classification with different models
model evaluation
and eventually a number of projects that
you can develop
so that you are independent in what you
do
okay so the question there is is the
data science program part of the premium
code package or is there another fee
these interactive programs are comprised
of different aspects of these elements
that we presented today so beeps thank
you for
pasting that link i will just briefly
show you
uh how you can learn about the pricing
of the different elements so if we go to
the data science program
just move this out of the way
data science
the data science program includes
access to programs
to courses sorry to the code playground
interactive sessions and also
independent projects that you can
develop
with our tutorials you have also have
some
advanced options as well if you want to
get mentor support
or if you have a project a research
project in mind
you can actually add on educational
cloud pipeline so you can run pipelines
on our big data server because that's a
major limitation for those that want to
work with big data sets from cancer
biology
and others that really gigabytes and
terabytes of storage are needed to be
able to process
those so there are a number of different
options for this
these programs start and end at a
certain time so the data science and
introduction to bioinformatics
already started this week if any one of
you wants to join we only did
introductory sessions up until now so
the registration is still
open until the end of this week but we
will continue to
repeat these programs every year
so the programs are built around a
six-month cycle
and we also offer a research internship
and the research internship is really
designed for those that
want a more flexible schedule and they
really prefer to work on independent
projects instead of following a specific
curriculum
so if we are just following
the existing curricula that we have with
dates
with setup times and topics that are run
you join a training program if you want
a flexible schedule
and you want to work on an independent
project we actually have a number of
students
that are working on their own research
projects and we have a number of
examples of what
those projects look like if you would
like to know
and those are also available as a part
of
a regular interaction with a mentor
and you can actually find
uh this fellowship information we call a
research fellowship
right here on this link okay just a
couple of questions let me address those
okay so if a course has a star that
means it's a premium course
if you have a subscription it's a basic
subscription i'll
pass it on to mohit here in just a
couple of minutes to talk about the
basic subscription
we offer a very basic beginner
subscription
for code omixlogic.com or for the
educational portal
that includes everything you need to do
asynchronously
at just ten dollars a month uh so
you could really do this um at any time
and uh yes so most of what we talked
about
can be done in the cloud and that's what
it's built around but if you want to do
it locally
you can obviously do that as well you
just don't get the points
that we keep tracking in our system
okay so let me pass it on to mohit
mazumdar
who will explain how the basic
membership works
and what types of resources are included
in the basic membership
for those of you that are interested in
the asynchronous options
thank you
okay uh hello everyone i'm with mazumdar
and i'm one of the global
representatives of find biotech
and in this role i'm helping students
and researchers
to learn about big data in biology today
i want to take you through our online
courses that are now
available for everyone to take under
a bundled under the basic subscription
so if you want to learn about
transcriptomic data analysis here is a
complete guide of rnsp
analysis transcriptomics one is an
introduction to next generation
sequencing to study the rna-seq
express expression data transcriptomics
2 is a course about
gene expression analysis and focuses on
studying variations
in expression between conditions so you
will learn about
factor regression analysis and t-test
and learn about the statistics
that statistics applied for this big
data
transcriptomics 3 is a course dedicated
to analysis
advanced analysis methods such as a
machine learning
algorithms that allows us to find
meaningful
patterns in big data sets especially
complex patterns that are typical
in these rna-seq experiments and
transcriptomics 4
is a review of single cell rna data
analysis
and a study of time course data for
thousands of single cell samples so if
you're interested in
transatomic data analysis i would
recommend you to
check this course series and if you're
interested in genomics if you're
interested in learning about dna
and changes that happens to the genetic
code the
genomic series of course explains how
next generation sequencing can be used
to study genome
genetic variation that results in
phenotypic changes
so the introduction to genomic is an
introductory course android 3 and a free
course
and and genomic one covers practical
application of genomics
to research and medicine so you will
have
uh pipelines uh that you can build uh
in these courses so that gives you a
hands-on experience so genomic two
focuses on the analysis of a single
nucleotide variation snvs
and genome-wide association studies
geoart
and if you're interested in diving into
the world of microbiome then
please review this three-course series
about metagenomics
so introduction to metagenomics is again
a free course and it will familiarize
you with the ways microbiome influence
their hosts
and also you will learn how you can
study this unique community using
the ng ngs technology so
metagenomics one however focuses on the
impact of bacterial diversity
on human health so you will learn about
multiple types of sequencing methods
such as
16s rna and dna and then practical
analysis
of 6 16 s sequencing data using the t by
info platform
so uh in metagenomics 2 you will learn
about the
uh you will learn to compare microbial
composition in different conditions
and then learn about 16s amplicon
sequencing
and that also covers uh data 2 analysis
pipelines
so for advanced advanced research
and the fourth type of data type
the fourth data type is epigenome and if
you're interested to get an introduction
to mechanisms of this
non-coding gene expression regulation
then i would recommend this epigenetic
series
and where you will learn about the
regulation of gene expression
with regulatory rnas dna methylation its
mechanisms assays
to find it and study it and ways to
analyze this data
so the data that is associated with this
assays
such as bisulfite sequencing keystone
modifications in epigenomes and
also chiptek uh keepsake data analysis
and uh last uh not
so many methods in bioinformatics as you
know requires
this application so a in-depth
understanding of machine learning
algorithms and tools
so in the specialized course on machine
learning
we developed a series of courses for
practical tutorials
that provide the solid foundation for
students on this important topic
that are often uh you know misunderstood
because of this
uh boom and all so to
so topics that we review in this courses
includes data preparation data mining
classification model training validation
and many others
so in this course series uh you will
learn about
computational innovation and algorithmic
improv
improvements that are quite that have
been quite important for this biomedical
uh data discovery
uh um that we are seeing
so as india told you all these courses
that we discussed
are now bundled under a single basic
subscription
and which is available only for ten
dollars a month or
a monthly subscription and to subscribe
and start
this start your bioinformatics ngs data
research please use this
link feature if you can uh if you could
share the link for
a registration for the basic
subscription and uh
with this information i will pass it on
to elia to take this forward
thank you everyone
thank you mohit and thank you everyone
for joining us today
i did want to mention that we have
a number of options uh to
get started for free and so i do hope
that most of you that are here today
with us
will be able to get started for free
give us feedback
and try out some of these resources both
on the
edu portal you can try for free on the
code omixlogic playground you can also
get started for
free we're very interested in your
feedback so please do let us know
what you might have in mind for how you
can use this
uh in your either education in your
studies
or in your training as a faculty member
and we do have our team here with us
which includes
uh support at pine bio for
any questions any technical questions
that you might cross
that you might find on the platform and
the coding
or the courses and as well as
any kind of marketing questions if you
have any questions about registration
any question about the different
programs you can contact marketing at
pi dot bio uh so if you could please put
in that contact information here
thank you and if you're interested in
developing resources
for your um own training uh
i will be happy to interact with you
personally
my email is ilia pine.bio and i'm
looking forward to
to discussing the options for that
now those of you that would like to
receive a recording of this webinar
and see some of the other methods and
resources that we have please visit our
youtube channel
please beeps if you could paste the link
to our youtube channel as well
and obviously we will follow up by email
to share with you
the recording of this webinar and some
instructions on how to get started
that we covered in this session
thank you again for joining and looking
forward to
continuing to see more engagement
in these different courses that we
discussed today
and we will have another webinar very
soon
to continue to talk about how you can
build programs
based on some of these resources that we
have discussed
you